okay
lastly
there is now a very
strange situation in the state of
georgia
and as a result
donald trump has put out a bizarrely lit
sweaty endorsement video where the
background is bright trump is dark and
glistening and looks confused and
actually opens the statement by saying
hello i'm president donald trump
i guess he thinks his name recognition
has declined and some people might not
know who he is this is this is what i'm
understand what this video is
up until a few days ago
vernon jones was running against david
perdue for governor of georgia so
remember david perdue was a senator from
georgia he ultimately lost to john
ossoff in that special election on
january 5th of 2021 and then david
perdue said i'm going to run for
governor vernon jones also running for
governor against david perdue drops out
a couple days ago and says i'm actually
going to run for uh representative for
the house of representatives it's not
because he's a great supporter of david
perdue it's because he realized he has a
much better shot of winning in the house
of representatives than he does at
defeating david perdue for the
governorship so the the timing is all
bizarre and trump says well this this
guy's a big supporter of purdue not
really he was actually running against
him and every aspect of this is just
strange the lighting is weird the
delivery is weird it has a sort of
hostage video feel let's take a look at
that hello i'm president donald trump
and when it comes to georgia's 10th
congressional district right i have only
one choice and the man's name is vernon
jones a very special person
he's an america first fighter who'll
never back down to either the
establishment or the radical left
few fought harder for election integrity
in 2020 than vernon and he's a big
supporter of a very good man running for
governor david perdue he has my complete
and total endorsement vernon will not
let you down
let's send a true patriot to congress
okay so there is donald trump and the
lighting is reminiscent of what uh
director of photography gordon willis
developed for the godfather
uh just all very very strange and i just
cannot get a straight answer uh about
the timing of any of this it's all
extraordinarily uh strange
and uh oh and i'm i'm uh and the by the
way the other thing is we're going to
see the power of the trump endorsement
we're really going to see the power of
the trump endorsement at this point uh
donald trump claims to have just a
fantastic record as far as endorsements
go and we're actually going to review
that record tomorrow
in reality the record is not really that
great it's very average and it will be
interesting to see what that endorsement
record ends up being
in november of 2022 that's going to be a
big factor in determining whether trump
even runs or has a shot in 2024 do the
trumpians and trump endorsed individuals
win in the november midterms or do they
lose and we'll be watching those results
very very closely we have a fantastic
bonus show today remember the bonus show
attacked by alex jones oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad crazy on today's bonus show
by many economic indicators the economy
is strong
but voters are not feeling that it is
strong and that is another problem for
joe biden we're going to talk about that
on the bonus show
california is suing tesla
over allegations of discrimination and
harassment we're going to talk about it
and al franken remember al franken
senator democratic senator from minne
minnesota
uh he says it you know it would be
tempting to run for office again we're
going to talk about the legacy of al
franken and the circumstances of him
ultimately leaving office
all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by signing up at joinpakman.com we will
see you then
as someone who watches youtube you know
how annoying it is to watch ads at the
beginning of videos that are completely
irrelevant to the content you're
watching that's why you always click the
skip add button our sponsor thought
leaders has just launched a new
targeting tool that allows advertisers
to choose the precise videos where their
ads will appear using the advanced
search in the thought leaders platform
which is powered by ai you can actually
find youtube videos relevant to your
brand's messaging and with thought
leaders precision targeting you can
really make every view count optimize
your ad spend improve your conversions
when brands put their ads on relevant
videos they catch their audience when
they are most receptive and create a
more fulfilling enjoyable youtube
experience for everyone involved plans
start at just sixty dollars a month but
you can try it now for just thirty
dollars for the first month when you
click the link below and use the code
pacman at checkout